standard douglas morgan the new leader
of the las vegas raiders the first black
woman ever to become president of any
nfl team but she's been breaking
barriers in a male-dominated field long
before this position i sat down with her
as she shared her driving force and
plans for the season
it's been
a really surreal first month a whirlwind
of activity for sandra douglas morgan as
the new president of the las vegas
raiders this week kicking off a
partnership with viva airbus and the
excitement of the first preseason game
at home this sunday you come at a time
when there's been a lot of a lot of
change in the front office and you've
taken out a lot
what is your message to fans employees
and players about how you're going to
run the office well the the most
important obviously thing to all raiders
is always going to be fans in our raider
nation but we have to make sure that our
employees understand that every single
thing that we do is for that shield and
for the raiders and just the legacy and
the rich history that it holds she says
she wants to wipe the slate clean focus
on a fresh new future hold employees
accountable and lead by example which
this trailblazer is accustomed to doing
becoming the first black city attorney
in our state she served on the nevada
state athletic commission and was
appointed the first chairwoman of the
nevada gaming control board i mean you
have broken down barriers gaming
industry the sports world male dominated
it's incredible sandra walking in that
room and seeing that no one else kind of
in there looks like you and not letting
that hold you back and just believing in
yourself sandra credits her work ethic
to her parents who instilled the
commitment to hard work education values
of excellence principals sandra says
align well with the raiders organization
i am just so
truly happy to be a part of such a
historic organization that has always
prided itself on its values its
commitment to excellence its commitment
to diversity and equity and inclusion
and now that i'm in this position and
knowing that i have mark support to
encourage those principles you know not
only throughout the raiders but
throughout the nfl it just really makes
you know all of i think the work that
that i've done over the few over the
last you know decades much much more
sweeter
and sandra says her family husband and
two kids mean everything to her in
addition to her parents who still live
here and they all help keep her grounded